[Música]
la economía en directo américa ya está
conmigo en el estudio jorge hurtado
jorge muy buen día bienvenido vamos a
comenzar hablando del reino unido porque
hay muchas vacantes de empleo y también
déficit de profesionales así es ahí en
esa región las vacantes de empleo en
reino unido aumentaron un récord de casi
1,2 millones según cifras oficiales
estos días raúl hemos conversado
bastante sobre la crisis que atraviesa
reino unido donde hacen falta
profesionales en una variedad de
sectores económicos como resultado de la
salida del reino unido de la unión
europea y también de la pandemia de
coronavirus el instituto de estudios
laborales estima que reino unido tiene
un déficit de 900 mil trabajadores hay
que señalar que la recuperación
económica desde el cese de las
restricciones por kobe 19 ayudaron a
impulsar la contratación con un aumento
de 207 mil trabajadores en nómina entre
agosto y septiembre a un récord de 29.2
millones de trabajadores activos eso de
122 mil más que el nivel de febrero de
2020 el último dato que se tenía antes
de la pandemia del cómic 19 se espera
que las vacantes estimulen la
contratación sobre todo el gobierno
canceló varias ayudas que se daban por
la pandemia ahora vamos a hablar ahora
de las cripto monedas específicamente
del bitcoin así es el bid coin superó
los 57 mil dólares por primera vez desde
mayo y esto es un aumento del 90 por
ciento desde el mínimo de julio según
los analistas la tendencia es que supere
su máximo histórico de casi 65 mil
dólares desde abril entre las causas se
habla de la calma tras las iniciativas
por regular las criptas en los cripto
activos en eeuu y china así como el
ánimo por la posible aprobación de un
fondo cotizado de bitcoin por parte de
la comisión de valores de eeuu este
repunte de cripto monedas como el bit
con jeter se da en un contraste con el
sube y baja de las acciones los bonos y
el oro tras los recientes ataques de
nerviosismo en los mercados globales
jorge tiene un bitcoin que me puede
apresar todavía no estás muy pronto
jorge en el fondo monetario
internacional decidió mantener en su
cargo a su directo ahora toda la
polémica pues la mantuvieron ahí no no
sólo la la mantuvieron ahí sino también
el organismo expresó plena confianza en
su directora esto en respuesta a las
acusaciones en su contra cuando era
funcionaria del banco mundial por
supuestamente presionar para cambiar la
clasificación empresarial de china en el
informe de 2018 el fondo monetario
internacional aseguró que su revisión no
demostrado de manera concluyente que la
directora kristalina georgieva
desempeñar un papel inadecuado en su
anterior error como alta funcionaria del
banco mundial el organismo aclaró que la
investigación continúa y que eeuu el
mayor accionista el fondo monetario
internacional planea monitorear de cerca
esta investigación georgieva ha negado
continuamente las acusaciones en el
informe que la señala de presionar al
personal para beneficiar a china cuando
ella era una de las principales
funcionarios del banco mundial y el
precio del petróleo se mantiene en
aumento jorge con el plan alcanzó el
máximo tras el máximo de tres años al
ubicarse a 84,38 dólares ayer mientras
que el juez de texas cerró en 81 dólares
con 72 centavos
la cotización del preso mantuvo su
tendencia al alza alcanzando a niveles
máximos desde 2018 impulso
principalmente por la recuperación de la
demanda global así como la entonces la
escasez de suministros y raúl los
precios del carbón y el gas natural
también se han disparado en europa y
asia mientras las reservas se están
agotando antes del invierno del
hemisferio norte esto provoca un cambio
de productos derivados del petróleo como
el diésel
hay que mencionar que la oferta mundial
del crudo se ha visto afectada por la
decisión de la opep en conjunto con
otros productores de no aumentar la
producción para estabilizar un poco los
precios cobre y en nuestro segundo
bloque de economía pues ya hay me va a
deber los indicadores y también la cifra
el día ahora vamos a ver nuestro
reportaje del día le parece vamos a
manos